coronavirus first emerged in the Chinese
city of Wuhan in December there have
been tens of thousands of cases but
globally just 2% of those who have
contracted it have died
compare that with SARS which kills 10
percent and MERS
which killed 1/3 so how is it spread
it's clear the virus can be passed on
through close physical contacts and
there's growing evidence that it can be
passed on through droplets in a sneeze
or a cough some patients are reported to
develop conjunctivitis suggesting it can
be transmitted through the eyes and the
virus can survive for up to four days on
hard surfaces meaning it could be passed
on through indirect contact scientists
are monitoring how the current outbreak
develops to learn more the countries
outside of China and the cruise ships
are very important to help us better
understand what's called the
epidemiology of the disease how easily
it spreads from person to person
how fine-tuning on understanding of how
it spread and also looking at the
natural history of the disease from the
time of infection through to sickness
and either recovery or death despite the
large number of cases relatively few
people have died China says 80% of fatal
cases have been in people over 60 while
three-quarters had pre-existing
conditions but there are cases of
apparently healthy young people dying
including the Chinese doctor Lee wen
Yang who was just 34 meanwhile
scientists are still trying to work out
where the corona virus originated one
theory is that it came from bats which
passed it on to snakes which then passed
it on to humans but Chinese researchers
are now suggesting it may have come from
pangolins one of Asia's most trafficked
mammals the truth is very little is
known about this novel coronavirus